[Music]
had a nice couple days off and the
temperatures were mild actually the high
60s to even 70 degrees and now we cool
things off when i come back to work
63 our high today still above average
but cooler and we'll
see that cooling trend through tomorrow
too 44 overnight for the low
nice and chilly start for us now a
little more on that record dry streak so
it continues for
us all right at 234 days now since our
last
measurable rain but get this the clouds
we had yesterday that system brought
those clouds yesterday that track to the
south
actually brought rain beneficial rain to
phoenix
to uh southern arizona there in yuma
where they broke their dry streak look
at yuma 242-day dry streak that was more
than ours that was broken this morning
when they got over a tenth of an inch of
rain but we
still remain dry for now 58 in
centennial hills
somewhere coming at 53 57 for those of
you joining us from aliante
the east side 65 sunrise mountain green
valley and henderson 64-55
rhodes ranch and mountains edge you're
currently at 64
at this five o'clock hour 63 in front 57
boulder city death valley coming in
right now new number 66 degrees
clear skies doppler network shows those
clouds that brought us
up well the clouds are over earlier
today they've now moved off towards the
east
pivoting with that system now into the
four corners region
the showers they had in arizona mohave
county and also down
south have now started to decrease now
we're watching this one here
impacting the pacific northwest that
will dive down and increase our winds
for tomorrow
as far as precip goes look at that it
starts to head our way and then it just
fizzles
out we'll have several systems that will
track to the north of us
over the weekend into early next week
nothing expected here though but then we
get to later on the week
slight chances at least according to
this model that we could have
some showers around the region still not
too big on the prospects of us getting
any rain here but that could
change and we'll let you know if that
happens as we get through the
forecast through the weekend next week
all right breezy ones expected tomorrow
they'll pick up
mainly uh peak midday and also the
afternoon and then decrease more for
tomorrow night for your friday so
41 overnight mostly clear and chilly
light winds overnight tomorrow we'll
have
winds become breezy like we pinpointed
out to you sun in the morning
and clouds will increase through the day
for tomorrow those winds will be up to
gusting up to 25 so no wind advisories
will be needed we'll keep around clouds
and sun
over the weekend keep it nice and cool
and get this look at this stay seasonal
your average next week too with plenty
of sunshine until we get to the end of
the week more breezy winds
and clouds will return again that's your
most accurate update
denisov